doch wieder atomkraft die mehrheit der
deutschen will genau das inzwischen klar
weil die energie gerade so knapp und zu
teuer wird weil die preise explodieren
explodieren doch wieder atomkraft der
politische druck von ihm auch der wächst
massiv auch von ihm heute kommt
deutschland dieser atomkraft wende
wieder einen schritt näher es geht genau
um dieses atomkraftwerk dieses
kernkraftwerk isar 2 sie weiter voll
dagegen ricarda lang die grünen co
chefin eines der letzten drei deutschen
kernkraftwerke ende dieses jahres soll
in isar 2 kein strom mehr produziert
werden aber jetzt machen die beiden
druck hier friedrich merz rechts im bild
cdu-chef und markus söder csu chef beide
besuchen das hier isar 2 in wenigen
stunden und was das heißt es doch völlig
klar druck auf die regierung die
botschaft wir wollen noch atomkraft wie
die mehrheit der deutschen jetzt jetzt
soll die regierung handeln der kanzler
der schwand noch schließt die atomkraft
wende längst nicht mehr aus das ist das
was er vor 24 stunden dazu gesagt hat
was die energieversorgung in deutschland
betrifft sind die drei letzten
atomkraftwerke wie jeder weiß
ausschließlich relevant für die
stromproduktion und nur für einen
kleinen teil davon aber trotzdem kann
das sinn machen das kann sinn machen
sagt also der kanzler und die
außenministerin die grüne annalena
baerbock die sagt dass dazu vor wenigen
stunden sie schließt nämlich genau das
kategorisch aus als mitglied der grünen
sind laufzeitverlängerungen für mich
keine option sagt sie also da ist
software indiaca wende heute kommt
deutschland möglicherweise einen schritt
näher durch diesen politischen druck den
die opposition heute aufbaut friedrich
merz markus söder zu besuch bei isar 2
und wir schauen uns die wesentlichen
fakten zur atomkraft hier in deutschland
noch mal an das ist die aktuelle karte
der kernkraft in deutschland
33 atomkraftwerke noch im moment am netz
isar 2 taucht hier zweimal auf weil es
noch zwei blöcke gibt von isar 2 emsland
und neckarwestheim 2
das sind die atomkraftwerke die bis ende
dieses jahres also noch kernkraft noch
strom liefern ja und wir schauen uns
dieses isar 2 atomkraftwerk noch mal ein
bisschen genauer an das atomkraftwerk
was am leichtesten ein bisschen
zumindest ein paar monate länger laufen
könnte es da im landkreis landshut seit
2011 ist der eine blog dort von isa
abgeschaltet und mittlerweile seit märz
2011 eben nur noch dieser block 2 im
betrieb und jetzt läuft voll die
diskussion an deswegen markus söder
friedrich merz heute zu besuch dass man
das eben wenigstens ein paar monate
länger laufen lassen kann
[Musik]